now we had all the ingredients we had
purified microtubules made from purified
tubulin we had the membrane organelles
we had the chemical energy source ATP
and now we can add them in various
combinations and see what might work to
allow this magical process of organelle
transport to occur in the test tube we
found that when we added organelles
microtubules and ATP surprisingly there
was no movement but we found that the
organelles themselves were not capable
of moving until we added this soluble
protein fraction and finally we saw
tremendous movement of these organelles
along the microtubules this was a really
exciting moment I been working
essentially for 4 months to get these
organelles to undergo motility in a test
tube just like in the native axon but
the next experiment was even more
surprising it was called a control
experiment essentially wanted to make
sure that what we thought we saw moving
we're in fact the membrane organelles
and not something else that might have
been coming along with the soluble
protein fraction so the way to figure
that out was just to mix everything
again but leave out the membrane
organelles just add together the
microtubules the ATP and the soluble
protein fraction and we thought nothing
would happen that we wouldn't see
anything and then we can call it a night
and go home but what happened was really
mind-blowing we looked under the
microscope in the microtubules which are
these long biological polymers we're
sliding around crawling around like
snakes on the glass surface that was
something that we certainly didn't
expect at all and in fact it even took
us a few minutes to even think about
what was happening here why were these
microtubules crawling along the glass
surface
after we overcome our amazement and
surprised by that result we then began
to piece together in our head what might
be happening
maybe that soluble protein fraction that
contains some agent that was causing the
organelles to move actually contained
the motor itself so the soluble protein
fraction had motors that were floating
around in it without the organelles and
these these motors would also be able to
stick onto the surface of this glass
slide grab hold of the microtubules and
transport these microtubules along the
glass think of a rock concert
the singer jumps off the stage into the
mosh pit and the people in the audience
who are stationary there grab hold of
the singer and transport the rock star
across we thought a very similar thing
was happening there with the
microtubules crawling on glass the next
day I was able to extend those results
to find that we could get plastic beads
in the presence of this soluble axon
plasmic protein fraction also to move
along microtubules and this is sometimes
what happens in science you know you
work really hard you don't get any
results it gets frustrating you have to
persevere and then one magical day
everything really seems to come together
and the experiment is suddenly propelled
much farther than you could have ever
imagined and that's a little bit the
nature of science it's one persistence
counts for a lot
one has to be prepared for the
unexpected and one has to believe that
one's experiment is going to work in the
very end and I think once one has that
kind of experience one's also willing to
persevere on
lot of other experiments later in one
scientific career as well
you